From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern Oral History Program.
I'm a professor at Chapel Hill.
I'm with the other first-genian Bishop in here in Richmond, Virginia,
to do an all-history and a view with Mr. Evans Derrell Hopkins,
and Evans Derrell Hopkins for the light and pleasure to be with you.
Pleasure to be with you.
Thank you.
The interview is being conducted for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
And, chopped, because I probably won't start today with the description of the family and childhood in the early years in Danville, Virginia.
Well, I was born on June 23rd, 1954, in Winslow Hospital, which was a one-floor hospital that was reserved for the colored citizenry of Danville, Virginia, so to speak.
My sister had been born a year before in Washington.
She had been my mother went up to Washington in order to give birth to her because of the segregation of the facilities.
And I wasn't quite so lucky, I guess, but I came through all right.
I had one sister, my mother, Margaret Hopkins, Margaret Swanson Hopkins from the Swanson family, and my father's name was Danville, Virginia Hopkins.
What about your parents and your sister?
Well, my mother and father met at a, during, in a typing class that was given by Dan River Mills back in during the day when, when many corporations sought to help out their workers with various self-help programs.
My father worked for Dan River Mills. My mother didn't, but she was in the typing class, along with her mother's matter of fact.
And they met and went. They went in their thirties at the time.
And my father began a landscaping business in addition to working for the meal.
He used to say that he was a black first. He was the first supervisor for Dan, black supervisor for Dan River Mills.
He was the supervisor of the mail room and the janitorial crew.
But first nonetheless, which shows you just how backwards Dan River Mills and segregated it was keeping all of the, or reserving all of the upper positions for the whites.
In any case, this was in the fifties, in the late fifties.
And he decided that he would bring the tractor from his family farm and begin a landscaping business in the city of Danville, Virginia, becoming one of the larger,
large-largest scrapers, which was not entirely very large for Dan River Mills.
But nonetheless, one of the very few black businesses in the town at one point.
Tell me a little bit about your sister, because of course she'll be important in the process by which you yourself will become involved in greater attention to civilizing.
My sister sort of led the way and influenced me to join the black Panther Party.
And you know, there were just the two of us.
I would say that probably my being involved in the church helped lead me toward a more strident involvement in the civil rights movement.
The High Street Baptist Church was the center of activity in 1963 for demonstrations that took place in Danville, Virginia, which to some extent are fairly well known.
But I'd like to read a section of my book on that, which might succinctly tell about what was going on in 1963 when I was nine, and what I entitled in the section of my book, Life After Life, a story of rage and redemption.
And the first section is entitled The Roots of Rage.
And the book begins with me as a young child, maybe six or seven.
The book begins with me.
Yes, excuse me.
The book begins with me, shopping with my mother at the A&P, which was one of the few stores that actually allowed or welcomed trade from the black people of the town.
And it's hard for people nowadays to think that stores were so segregated that even the grocery stores, there was only one grocery store that most of the black people used to go and shop at.
The A&P parking lot was beside the old city jail, and I would spend minutes there seemed like hours with my face close to the windshield, looking up at the hundred-year-old building spaded grayish white facade.
I would see the men inside with their arms sticking out through rusted iron bars, watch them waving or screaming or flinging nose to girlfriends or family members, standing at the fence along the edge of the lot.
The jail took on a more frightening aura when I turned nine.
It was then that police locked away hundreds of demonstrators during the civil rights marches of 1963, where firemen opened up on the crowds with water hoses, when deputized garbage men attacked them with clubs, and dogs were set upon those who came to the court's building to protest the mass jailings.
My family was embroiled in this struggle, and the image of the jail became embedded in my young mind, a fearsome symbol of the consequences of social change.
But as imaginative a child as I was, I could never have foreseen that one day I would be looking out of that A&P parking lot from the inside of that old jail.
You've written in your book about the theme of inevitable confusion for a young person coming up in a world that has all these arbitrary rules related to race.
I just wanted to ask you a little bit about that to expand on that issue of how as a young person, a child in that year, in 1963, you're just nine years old.
How you began to try to think your way through the question of race and racism and what you were observing.
Well, it was particularly hard during this era because of the thought that, you know, let me put it this way, everything around you tried to make you feel like you were in theory.
Okay, it made you want to feel like there was an innate in theory or a lot of being black.
And not only that, that white society, white culture, the white race, the white mind was superior.
So therefore, it was so deep that it even went as far as in my own family because my mother was lighter than my father.
My father was of a darker complexion because I was darker than my sister.
It's so the thought that could it be possible that one's mother might be superior to one's father or one sister superior to oneself?
You know, that's just how deep it was.
And in figuring it all out, sometimes I say, well, one of the things that inspired me to develop my mind more, studied in psychopedia and all of that,
was I didn't want my sister to be smarter than I was.
She was a year older, so naturally, she was more advanced in some ways.
But I wanted to prove that one, the times were relatively sexist as well.
So I couldn't let a girl do me as a boy.
But also, at the same time, I just wanted to prove that I was as good as my sister.
And when integration came, I had to strive to prove, constantly prove that I was as good as the white students.
Well, we'll reach that integration question just a minute.
I want to ask a little bit more about how your family was giving me a parents born in their histories, how your family was situated in relation to the white and black community in Danville.
Well, my mother's father was probably the most prominent African American in the city.
The story is told of how he built the houses on two streets in Danville called Bruce Street neighborhood, and in many other areas of Danville,
along with his sons who worked as his construction crew.
And this was around the turn of the century, early 1900s.
And around the 1920s, he wanted to buy a big brick house.
But all of the larger brick houses were up on just one street up on the white street, the West Main Street of Town.
So he went up there, he bought a house, and then moved the house, brick by brick, tore the house down in sections or brick by brick,
and reassembled the house one block away in Bruce Street neighborhood.
So we grew up sort of until the age of when I was six, we grew up in the big house.
You know, all of the other houses were a lot smaller.
And so it gave me a sense of privilege, but at the same time, we couldn't walk to the white street, you know, without worrying about we had to go up there to catch the bus, which we seldom did,
because our parents didn't want us subjected to having to sit in the back of the bus.
And then one other street over behind our house was another white street.
And to a child, you would tell, you know, you go there and, you know, the white folks are gitchy, and you might get into a fight or you might not come back.
So it was sort of like being imprisoned in one's own city to a certain extent.
You was a nine-year-old, the major demonstrations of Danville, Virginia. Of course, Danville, Virginia had a, well, let me put this way, Danville, Virginia's history through the civil rights areas is often described and written about by historians as being very rugged.
I mean, even the national landscape, a whole lot of difficult places.
Danville, Virginia was a pretty hard place through this era. And I'm wondering if that's your recollected sense and also, you know, how you might have come to whatever pin you have of that through observation about such.
Perhaps I could read another section of the book, which was better than as I might now.
In 1963, when I was nine, there were mass demonstrations in Danville, Virginia protest against the segregation of the bus lines, of the department stores, and perhaps most pointedly of the city library.
It was thin that my social consciousness began to develop with the first hand accounts I heard of boycotts and marches of the swinging police clubs and attacking dogs, of folk being knocked down by the force of fire hoses in the streets of my town, all melded with the terrible photos and television accounts of similar turmoil throughout the south.
I remember seeing bloody men and women come staggering into high street church for first aid. The black hospital was filled with wounded protesters that night.
And when those arrested went to court, they were tried before Judge Archibald M. Aiken., who would take a pistol from beneath his robe before each session and place it on the bench and an effort to intimidate any who would defy the racist laws.
But all of this only solidified my resolve and the resolve of those involved in the movement, and city leaders would eventually have to give in to our demands, but only after dictates from the courts.
While the buses and stores had been forced into integration, the library remained the last bastion of white supremacy and dangle.
When the courts finally mandated that the library integrate, I was overjoyed. I remember ranging a ride into town with a teacher after school and rushing to the main library to delve into the books that had been denied to me.
But once inside the library, I discovered that all of the tables and chairs had been removed. In a final attempt to maintain segregation,
city officials had decided that while blacks would have to be allowed into the library, they would not be permitted to sit and study alongside whites.
When I recall the shock of seeing the spieffulness of whites evidenced by the bare flaws of their library, I began to understand how anger turns into rage.
The difference between the high school and the town still.
Exactly. We're back on after a short break. I wanted to ask about the several years, 63 to fall, 69, I think, when you would enter the recently desegregated town still high school in Danville.
Talk about the choice, how your family resolved on the choice to send its children into the newly desegregated high school or on a small number of families that came on that front edge of that effort.
Well, it was either going there or to go into the city schools.
And...
It was a pause for a minute.
They had that brief interruption for a neighborhood to come to the front door.
All right.
Who's talking about 63 to 69 when you enter the high school?
Well, my parents felt that during this period, everyone felt like they had to do their part and to make some sacrifices to a certain extent.
And it was obvious the closest county high school was about 35 miles away.
It was actually the school. And one time I had thought that it was the reason that my father hadn't gone to high school was because there were no buses going to that high school 35 miles away.
Interestingly enough, I found out later on that that high school wasn't founded until I think the late 40s or early 1950s.
So when he was in school, there weren't any high school for black kids.
But in any case, this high school was so far away and there were no buses to take us there.
So it was actually integrated the county school or not go to high school.
Well, let me take that back. There were buses going 35 miles away.
So it was either by time we went to school.
So we felt that in order to get a better education, we had to integrate the school.
But we also wanted to be part of the effort to integrate the schools.
Talk about it.
I didn't like it very much.
I didn't like it at all.
To know how experienced you had and how you think and what on that experience today?
Well, you know, I was recently, I was watching all of these things about bullying and what bullying does to kids.
And I had never thought of myself as being bullied.
But then because it was a racial thing, I felt I had been harassed and intimidated and attacked physically.
I was attacked once and received a black eye and forgetting into a fight.
But I was attacked from behind. I was pushed. I was jostled.
I was cursed and called all manner of things.
But it wasn't as bad as many kids went through during that time.
But in my imagination, the young writers imagination, it was just horrific.
But in thinking about how that being bullied helped fuel my rage later on,
it helped me to feel like I needed to be more of a man, you know, to resist this sort of oppression.
So when kids go through it nowadays, I can identify with that.
But I had never really realized that that bullying was probably one of the most important aspects of my young life as far as turning me later towards.
The rage that led to...
I won't necessarily say the rage led me into the movement, but the need to resist led into the movement.
And later on, anger and rage found this way into my subsequent turn toward criminality.
I believe it was the summer of 1970 when the family made a trip up to the Washington D.C.
The first time a direct way encountered the message of Black Panther Party really newspapers and some relatives.
Yes. I had a cousin who was selling Black Panther Party newspapers.
And we saw the first paper, and by that time we had already been involved in an organization.
It was part of the cultural nationalist movement.
You know, we were wearing dashikis, afros, suddenly Black became beautiful.
And, excuse me, during this time, you know, one thinks back upon this period because it seems like now there is again a lack of a certain amount of culture identity in pride.
And, you know, I was not aware at that time, I guess I was a cultural nationalist to a certain extent.
But when I encountered the Black Panther Party, they had a message of not only racial solidarity, but class solidarity.
They put things into economic terms, but also the Black Panther Party was a seed of a growing movement toward pride in being Black, but also pride in resistance.
And during this time, there was a strain of fear. You have to remember that those who resisted were often met with the most terrible brutality.
And, you know, they were jailed after Klyma Thoregaev.
Excuse me.
The most terrible brutality.
And they were...it's no way to take that out of the tape.
And so there was a fear.
The fear was inordinately large compared to the actual actuality.
The terrorism of the Ku Kluss clan, our remember growing up, we always closed our drapes.
You know, I see people now with their windows open. And sometimes I think now, you know, we leave our windows open.
But back during that time, we said, better close those windows, you know, why folks would drive through and just shoot through your window, just for meanness and spite.
And so during that time there was an inordinate fear, you know.
The quote unquote white man was all powerful. He could do anything to you.
If you just acted like you were an up-and-dead Negro or anything like that, or you tried to move above your station or get out of your place.
You know, you don't hear these terms anything, but, you know, it's up-and-dead Negro above your station out of place.
You know, these were, this was all throughout the South, but also throughout the North, but particularly throughout the South.
Do you have a more about that in that year, fall of 7th, the 77 one school year will culminate in the spring with an effort by yourself and a friend to read a student walk out, which has a,
and a beautiful sort of resolution in the moment when you arrived at the school.
Right. Well, we had planned the walk out because the schools had integrated.
And one school was called John M. Langston High School after one of the first, I think, was members of the House of Representatives.
The first black, one of the first black representatives during the reconstruction era.
And the high school was named George Washington.
So Langston was more or less, it wasn't abolished.
It was turned into actually a middle school.
And so Langston High School was abolished and it had the storied history dating back years and years.
So the students felt like their identity had been taken.
So we wanted a new school.
We wanted to get rid of the name of George Washington.
We felt George Washington was a slave owner.
And we just wanted African American studies classes or black studies classes.
We just wanted a sense of identity of our own.
And so we decided to stage a walk out so that we could have these things that we wanted.
And the walk out was supposed to be in for a Thursday.
We planned it on a Tuesday.
We had a student group that used to sell black Panther Party newspapers.
So I was the titular head of this little group of community workers.
We used to go to Winston-Salem North Carolina, whether it was a black Panther Party chapter,
and get the newspapers and come back.
And so we planned this walk out.
And someone leaked word that we were going to walk out on Thursday.
They leaked word on Wednesday.
And I got to school.
Everybody was already out on the hill who were, you know, people were going to walk out about 150 students,
including some white students.
Because working with the black Panther Party, we were told to educate the whites as well.
That they weren't getting their proper history as well as far as the class struggle that was going on.
And, well, two things that, you know, I'd like to come back to as far as dealing with the black Panther Party,
or two things in particular, and that's idealism and ideology.
Because a lot of people don't understand it.
Think of the black Panther Party as being kind of like a quote unquote black clan,
but it wasn't anything of the sort.
It was an internationalist philosophy organization.
Basically, I would say Marxist-Leninist philosophy, except that we were taught that Marx would not have called himself a Marxist.
So it was more or less socialist and philosophy.
So I got to the school and everybody was already out there,
and but we didn't get half the kids that we had planned to get.
And so we ended up, I had to negotiate with the principal, and I got kicked out of school for three days,
along with the organizers, four or five of us.
And so it sort of started my career as a revolutionary off on a rather comical footing,
but it also the police did not attack us.
And this was in the era just before.
I think it was the spring of Kent State, as a matter of fact.
So we were fairly daring.
I think it might have been just after the Kent State uprising.
And we were a bit incensed by that as well.
So some of the turmoil that was going on on the college campuses around the Vietnam War
was spilling over into the high school campuses.
So if we had not had the white kids with us, I, you know, dread to think what might have happened.
Tell me a little bit more about this simultaneous process that's happening across that last year,
last year in Dando's high school student.
Well, you're making these period of visits down to Dandoents and Salem,
and really becoming more substantially engaged with the flat-after chapter there.
You describe your impressions of the group and how you began to understand that there would be roles
and opportunities available for you in that context.
Well, I guess to a certain extent, I felt that maybe I had an inordinate idea of my ability to be a leader.
But I was advanced in a sense philosophically.
I loved studying the philosophy of the Panther Party.
I loved studying dialectical materialism, which was sort of like our textbook,
the philosophy of the socialist Marxist-Linanist groups.
I love the fact that the idea of searching for truth and the fact that the Panthers felt like
they had a kernel of real truth of what was going on in the world.
And I felt that I would be able to, because of what they called my quote-unquote bourgeois education,
that I would be able to lend my services and my abilities to the movement.
So by this time I'd read the autobiography of Malcolm X,
H, some of H, rap, brown, some of Irish cleaver.
So now I realize that this was the budding writer in me.
I'd read the prison letters of George Jackson.
And I knew that I wanted to write.
I had had a couple of the teachers in high school,
white teachers as a matter of fact, and one black teacher when I went to school in the city,
who told me that I wrote rather well.
And I liked hearing that.
I liked being able to communicate on paper.
I was a rather shy young man.
So I didn't do a lot of talking.
I wasn't able to like many of the Panthers blow on people.
That was the term that was used.
You got to blow on the masses and get them to understand where you're coming from.
And to a certain extent I was mesmerized by the fervor of their speech.
And I was taken also by their culture.
This was to a sense authentic African American culture to me.
They were cool.
Many of them were swall.
But also they were very dedicated.
They weren't the pictures that we had seen of the Panthers in Regale.
You're marching with Berets.
Many of them were relatively impoverished.
When I went there, they were sleeping on mattresses.
They were living in what we call shotgun apartments.
I didn't even know what a shotgun apartment was during that time that you could joke was.
If you fire a shotgun from the front door, it would go through the three rooms,
the middle room, the middle room, the bedroom, and the kitchen, and out the back door.
It was a time of me understanding more about my culture.
I was just taken with the dedication.
I worked 16, 17 hours a day, go out selling papers.
We ran a free breakfast program.
This was after I joined because as soon as I turned 17 and became of age,
I left Danville and went to Weston Salem and lived with the party.
Tell me more about that experience of the year in the Uranus Consale
and becoming more direct and substantial engage,
including before that year as a up, you will be formally made a member of the party,
which was not an automatic and automatic stretch.
During that time, the Black Panther party began in 1966.
It was founded by Huey Newton and Bobby Seale.
Bobby Seale later told me that his conception of the organization was sort of as a civil rights organization.
They wrote up the platform program, the 10-point platform program,
in the office of an anti-poverty program where Bobby Seale worked.
But the idea was to have these various programs that would help develop the Black community,
not just be an anti-poverty program, but a program that would help economically develop the Black community.
But the first and foremost, they felt the Black community had to be defended against the police forces of the time,
who were just wrapping in the brutality that was going on in the communities.
Most of the police forces were all white and the brutality that the community endured was legend at that time.
So it sort of had morphed for a while, particularly during the period when Huey Newton, he went to prison in 1967.
Bobby Seale was in jail for the march on the Sacramento capital of our march.
So the party was leaderless, but it expanded so quickly and rapidly.
There were chapters just coming up everywhere, but they weren't really affiliated with the national organization.
So membership was shut down after Huey Newton's return.
And David Hilliard was in charge, so membership was shut down, and you could only become a community worker for the Panther Party until you were a quote-unquote Panther training for a while,
and then you would become a full-fledged member.
So I was a community worker in Winston-Salem, and looking back, this was probably one of the happiest years of my life before I went out to Oakland,
and a lot of turmoil resulted from that trip.
But I graduated from high school, worked in the community, worked in the free breakfast program, I can still feel how hot those grids were on those thin paper plates and serving the kids.
And it really helped to formulate my concept of community service.
I want to ask a little more about the Winston-Salem year, in particular around the following question, this is such a central part.
I think it's fully fair to say about the context in which the Panthers emerged into their work.
And you've mentioned police brutality in all of its manifestations of every local context, pretty much, where the movement unfolded.
In the late 60s, Hoover, the FBI, COINTELPRO really came down hard with Panthers, and even by the time 1971 or 172, you were in Winston-Salem, I think nearly 30 members of Panthers had been killed.
And while your Winston-Salem George Jackson dies, and I'm interested to reflect on the question of the nature of struggle, the inclusion of self-defense, the inclusion of the prospect of harm resistance in that kind of context,
you were a young man, finally, where forward, and how those things, how you thought about that question in that year?
Well, luckily I joined the Panther Party in the year of 1971. This was after Huey Newton had returned from prison, and there was a break in which Eldridge Cleaver had what we called defected or tried to split the party.
Actually, it's hard to say it was a split because it was really just the New York chapter, primarily the New York chapter, and the international group around Eldridge Cleaver.
However, it was also a split in philosophy because Eldridge Cleaver at the time was expousing, taking the struggle to a quote-unquote higher level of harm struggle, which would include in his mind the minds of many of those around him, attacks upon the police, and attacks upon other armed forces,
in order to quote-unquote hide the contradiction with the oppressor forces. Huey in a series of pieces wrote about the necessity to get away from the party's mode of being what he would call a cultist type of organization, not a cult.
But there was a cultural aspect around resistance, which glorified the gun. So he said that it was necessary to put away the gun and to only utilize or keep the gun for self-defense because the gun had also become a symbol of aggression against the power structure in a way that it was seen at that time.
So it was a time that it would not work. Now, having joined at that time, I still romanticized about the ideal of armed struggle, which is not talked about a lot, but that ideal was still sort of in the background.
So we had a very survival program, free grocery program, free busing to prisons program, free medical clinics, and all of these were to serve the community to help the community see us as being on their side.
But we also called them survival programs. It was called survival till revolution.
So the idea that a revolutionary time would come again was still very much in our minds. It began to recede in the years of 72, 73, and 74 because we also had decided that we would work within the system to change the system from within.
And Bobby Seale ran for mayor of Oakland, which ended up with most of the party chapters actually being dismantled. And it was said that they were going to be dismantled temporarily.
But instead, they were more or less dismantled for good, and most of the membership brought out to Oakland, California, as was I.
I went out to become the revolutionary wall correspondent that I had always dreamed of being ever since I read about Clark Kent, I guess, being a reporter.
I'm not sure where it came from, but the ideal of writing about being a walker, a correspondent, a lie, a himing way, that sort of being appealed to me.
What we want to say when we think of this history from this distance today, sometimes we smile as you just have, but it also strikes me as altogether straightforward and understandable that you would have felt the way that you did in that context.
You would have been sincerely motivated around these questions and truly committed to what you considered a program of perspective social change that clearly was fully justified, motivated by the circumstances of the life that you could see from the Americans everywhere around you.
I'm interested in the question of how you felt about these prospects and how, as you were still a very young man, young adult, how you found a role for yourself.
I think that you mentioned more correspondent, obviously, would emerge effectively as a journalist inside the historian and reporter inside the party.
So I'm just wondering how you came into work for young self in those years in these new roles, doing these tasks for the party?
Well, I was fortunate in that, as soon as I got to Oakland, I think this was the August of 72.
Soon after, maybe within two or three months, where I became a part of the newspaper cadre, as it was called, or the editorial cadre, which was about five or six who worked, who wrote on the paper, but we had about five or six layout people led by Emory Douglas, the renowned artists.
And then we had typesetting people, and then we had central distribution, which sold the paper and sent it out nationwide.
But for the editorial cadre, those who wrote for the paper, David Dubois came and became the editor-in-chief of the paper.
And David Dubois was the son of W.E.B. Du Bois and Shirley Graham Du Bois, the step son of W.E.B., and he had edited the English-speaking daily in Cairo, Egypt for the previous 12 years.
And he became my mentor and a good friend, and sadly passed away just before the publication of my book, but he did get a chance to review it and to write a blur for it, to which I am thankful.
And so, if any, researchers, I wasn't able to get hold of his papers, and I still want to try to find his papers because he was working on a book on the party.
So, if any, researchers are watching this, is sometimes, please contact me.
But in any case, David basically taught me how to write. He taught me the, I think I took a couple of one or two, I had a weekend at the college, which didn't turn out as I planned, but because I felt like I was learning more, just working and writing for the party.
And, but, you know, the fundamentals of journalism, and basically the sensibilities of literary artists as well, because David was working on a novel.
And I said, well, why would a revolutionary writer, Evel Wright, fiction, and he said, well, sometimes you can get it greater truths with fiction, and then with nonfiction.
And he was working on a novel, which was later published called, and bid him sing, in which he had a young artist over in Cairo, meeting Malcolm X during Malcolm X's Hodge.
And I'm not sure it's still in print, but it comes to mind now.
So, during this period, you know, this was a period in which my horizons grew politically, because as soon as I got there, I was covering during 1972-73, the, I was covering the campaign by Bobby Seale from Mayor of Oakland, and Elaine Brown was running for City Council during that time.
And so, I, by being, I was the writer and the sound man, so my job was to catch all of their words on this, your brand, real to real tape recorder.
So, I'm actually in a few shots. I even have a newspaper, which maybe I like to get a shot of, in which Bobby Seale is running for mayor, and he's speaking, and he's, and I'm there with a microphone, you can sort of barely make me out.
But, and then there's a shot in a book by Stephen Shames, which might be included, I don't know, in a future exhibit, but he has a book out which I'll show you a copy of, which also has a picture of me with, at 18 years old, with Bobby Seale on the bus.
It was in a photo that was in Jet Magazine. So, this also helped me to realize the ideal of, of being well known, I'm being, I'm around people who are famous, you know, the ideal of, maybe it helped me in terms of feeling like I can speak to and reach the masses.
I'm writing in a paper that's being read by thousands of people going all over the country and all over the world. So, it helped to formulate my sustainability as an artist. I met people like Abbey Lincoln, for instance, who was a good friend of David Graham Du Bois.
When you asked about, in a more day and day sense, what it felt like, you were doing, you were doing very, very interesting circumstances. You covered the trial with San Juan VI, and you were, you were, thickly in the campaign next for the concept of mayoral race.
What did it, at all? You were describing the context of feeling the, the urgency.
It, you know, I work with young people now, and I've done some, a lot of some research and activities as it relates to formulation of one's heroes.
So, during this particular time, I was able to formulate my ideal of the heroic male and the heroic female because we had some very strong women leaders in the party as well.
On the other hand, it led to a certain amount of disillusionment when the party began to fall apart, and I found out that the feet of many of these heroes were made of clay.
But at that time, I was, you know, in part of researching about what goes on in the minds of youth, and subsequently when I sort of veered off the path of, of a political struggle.
I have done some reading, and there's been a lot of research on how the young mind develops.
The mind at 20 years old, my mind at 18, 19, and 20, I realized was still developing at that time. My brain was still developing.
So, there was, to an extent, a sense of a bond reality. You know, there was a sense that we could change the world.
We really believed that we could change the world, but the world was changing so quickly, you know, that it was sort of easy to believe.
You know, there were developments in music, in jazz, in film. The first black films were coming out. Some very progressive mainstream and independent filmmaking was being done.
So, I felt like, I remember during the trial, I mean during the campaign of Bobby Seale, Bert Schneider actually came and was shooting a documentary on the campaign.
He was a good friend of, of Huey Nunes, and so I remember meeting Bert Schneider, so I said, that's Bert Schneider.
He was Bert Schneider. He made Easy Rider. I'm like, once Easy Rider, you know.
So, but the guy who was doing the shooting for the documentary, and this is just an aside, was actually the guy who invented the steady-can.
And so, you know, things were happening at this particular time, and I'm learning about radio, mics, film, and all of this.
But there was a sense of unreality to a certain extent. I won't say of surreality. It wasn't quite surreal.
But the moments were very alive. I just begun smoking marijuana, so out in California.
To a certain extent, I've often thought about it in listening to the song, Hotel California. You know, you can check out anytime you want, but you can never leave.
Did you think that you had a feeling of sealed with winter airs?
You know, often when I watch political campaigns now, and I wonder when people lose fairly badly, and I'm wondering, how could they have thought they were going to win?
But we actually thought we were going to win. We thought we were going to win.
And it's often when I also think about illusion. That's such a thing as positive illusion.
Certain things you can't do unless you actually believe you can do them, no matter how far fetch they may seem, like right now I'm writing a movie.
And I'm going to get this movie made, but you know, I've never made a film before, you know, or written a film.
But it's going to get made, but it would never have gotten ridden.
Had it not been for the fact that I could imagine, you know, actually getting it made.
We thought he was going to win, and then when he barely ate into a runoff, it was sort of like, we knew that really the only chance we had is if we were to win the main election because the vote was split.
But there was another black candidate, which split the black vote.
So when we forced the runoff, the main candidate, which was the incumbent mayor, was so far ahead, we sort of conceived that we weren't going to win the runoff.
But up until that point, we believe we were going to take over Oakland.
Tell me more about David Boyz, than you were supposed to be.
David was a very learned man. He spoke with a British accent.
He talked about his father, a great deal, which also helped me to develop a sense of wanting to be a social scientist in many ways.
He, you know, and Du Bois inspires me to this day.
And just the sense of knowing someone who gave an international flavor, who had studied and lived in China, who had studied and lived and worked in Cairo,
it helped widen my horizons to understand that I could reach a wider world.
And it was also just good to have someone who understood and loved the English language the way he did.
And so having him to edit my words, he drew the best out of me, you know, helped me to develop an early sense of style and an early sense of color and to be able to see detail.
And to see the humanity in the details of what I was covering and it helped me to develop a cinematic eye.
And to a certain extent, I guess you'll be talking in this series to a lot of activists.
Perhaps I should speak to the role of the artist and culture and the development of the civil rights movement.
And to a certain extent, I became an artist because of my involvement in the civil rights movement and the desire to communicate with others.
But to an extent, my sensibility as an artist, I was not an artist in the movement, but my sensibility began to develop from that.
And my ability to see the humanity, to understand my own theory of moral understanding, to develop a moral compass that would later after I straight away from it as a sort of detail in my book.
But to help me to rejoin the world of man, so to speak, and to be able to utilize my words in a poetic sense.
And so when you look at the music of the movement, you look at the words, you look at the preaching.
A lot of people, and I've seldom heard people talk about the use of story, allegory, color, and poetic phrasing in the rhetoric of preaching and in the rhetoric of the movement.
But if you listen to a feministist, Ma'an Lupi King, you will hear, it's almost like a Shakespearean type of use of rhetoric.
Let me ask about two aspects of the spring of April of 1973, was the end of the campaign, the final election cycle.
And fairly shortly thereafter has really started to crumble party inside the party.
And I want to say, in your perspective on that, it would draw you into very, kind of, you write about very bitterly, but very unusual, disciplined or in context inside the party.
And you're also time-striving with extremely limited resources, and that would have forced certain choices of money.
So you talked to the first on that, first thing about the tensions and desegregation of the coherence of the party in the club after the 1973 campaign.
Well, sometimes I've heard people say it was kind of like the Berlin Wall coming down, you know, what do you do next?
And to a certain extent, you know, a lot of people, everything had been put into trying to get Bobby elected.
So, you know, some people wanted to go back to their home chapters.
It was hard for the party to maintain discipline.
At the same time, the leadership, particularly, Huey Newton, and those around him, the inner core, particularly his security detail.
They were sort of trying to maintain their power, but a lot of the problems came from money.
There wasn't enough money to run the organization without some of the political donations.
We needed money to run the programs.
And so the day-to-day operations of the party, we thought that idealistic notion of attaining power politically, the cohesiveness began to die away.
And it led to a certain amount of dissension.
When there were, you know, and a lot of problems came from the use of physical methods of corrections, as they were called, which could include a flogging of party members.
And not just the members who were abused, you know, there was an attitude of fear, which I guess could be related to other totalitarian regimes, so to speak.
And, you know, many members whose ideals were related to freedom just weren't able to deal with that.
And so the fabric, the thread of the party, began to unravel.
You seem a little more about, as I say, you're very vivid about this in the book, about the occasion of your encounter in this physical violence inside the party and how it would be one of the episodes in quick sequence that lead you to leave.
Well, to a certain extent, I was afraid when I wrote quite candidly about what happened with me, to a certain extent, you know, I was afraid that it would be dwelled upon, you know, the irony of an African American who's a great person.
And whose ancestors were whipped, encountering the same sort of thing.
But, you know, I did it in the context of basically this was after I hissed toll in a car.
And I was planning a robbery, you know, now granted in my young adolescent mind I had hooked up with some people outside of the party.
And I told them that I needed money because my idea was to bring out my pregnant fiance from Winston Salem out to California.
And I never really thought about committing a criminal act until then.
And so I fell in with the guy who was an armed robber and he said, well, I know where we can get some payroll.
So I stole in a car in order to, to, to, to, to form at that scheme.
And so that was one of the problems that I guess the party leadership felt they had to deal with, which is we don't want to turn someone over to the police.
I had been busted, you know, so I was faced with going to jail.
But I ended up not having to.
But, you know, so how do you discipline, you know, and sometimes some of the other sanctions were quarters restriction,
marijuana restriction, you know, various other sanctions.
So this is one of the things that, you know, that I dealt with in the book.
I didn't want that iron need to be a central part.
But I guess to a certain extent it points out that the problems and the, and the autocratic nature, that the, of what the organization was going through.
And how many of the, you know, you had a strong central committee, but the authority of the central committee was being usurped.
You know, you had a central committee made up of leaders of the various chapters who were out in Oakland at the time.
And, and you had some factions to develop from that.
But it, it's all sort of led to the period in which I left.
You had a sort of a mass exodus of maybe, I don't know, maybe, I won't say schools, but it might have been schools of party members in that, in that one period.
And this was a period also when he, when he knew and had gone off the rails, when later on it, it came out that he was doing great amounts of cocaine, drinking a great deal of cognac.
And then he got charges for Huey Newton's 1977 pistol-whipping of his tailor, and then he shot a woman and who later died and he ended up fleeing to Cuba.
And it was during this period that you had a mass migration from the party and it turned out that I happened to leave during the same, same weekend when he left.
During the same weekend that he went to Cuba.
It was possible.
Well, we're back on after a short break.
And, I wanted to ask about a bunch of earlier, some very strong women in the party and I'm interested in the perspective on kind of evolving notions of gender women, their readership, their, their place in the culture of that struggle.
Well, luckily the party had the philosophical ideal that women were equal to men, that gender inequality was part and partial of the white patriarchal system.
And so sisters were encouraged and they sort of banded together and said things like, you know, sisterhood is powerful.
You know, this was also during the feminist movement.
So, and many, there were quite a few women in leadership positions. It was said at one time that women made up maybe 48% of the party.
I'm not particularly sure, but I know out in Oakland that that was largely the case.
The men still maintained most of the positions of authority, except during one period and then there was a group on the Central Committee, which actually might have been after I left, might have had actually a predominance.
But by and large women had positions of authority. I learned to work with them. Could you cut just a moment?
Okay.
Women, you know, I learned to work with them and under them. I also learned to a certain extent that many of them have a certain amount of baggage and some of this has come since then.
And they sometimes women, I think, carry a little resentment. And I think that this was a case with some of the sisters that I worked with in the party, but by and large women in the civil rights movement in total probably had a greater role than even women in larger society and social struggle.
Probably even greater than the civil rights movement simply because there are several reasons. One is that black women were generally better educated and were able to withstand certain of the vicissitudes of the educational system.
That would tin and I think a lot of this is going on now with young black males, many of the young females are able to deal with the structure of the system and don't get the anti-black masculine bias that many teachers in the educational system had.
So to a certain extent, you find within the civil rights movement within the post civil rights movement, but one has to position the black Panther Party as part of the civil rights movement, the latter part, much as SNCC was.
But women were more involved because women had been able to attain a lot educationally. And also women had learned a lot from the larger culture, from positions of employment, whereas men may have been in factories, women by virtue of working in white households to a certain extent.
So the women in the United States, women by virtue of working in white households, women by virtue of working in white households to a certain extent, had gotten a certain amount of cultural enrichment and education.
But it may be, it may not be. But in any sense, one would think that this is something that helped in terms of fueling the movement as a whole.
You had women who were able to get a certain amount of cultural development and educational enrichment in their homes. They were able to bring it home to their kids.
They were able to help in terms of developing the men in their families. Just as, for instance, my mother, my father was unable to get a secondary school education, but my mother had a college degree in Mauser teacher.
So these are things that were able to help in terms of having an equality of the sexes in the movement.
I want to ask before you move on to something. It's just for a final one. You haven't had that past, and I'd be interested in it.
Oh, excuse me. One other point on that. Also working with white women who weren't as emeshed in the ideals of white patriarchy.
I think that also helped black women to be able to develop more enlightened view on things. And that dates back to slavery times and hired beacher stole even.
You asked for your perspective on Bobbyshire?
Bobbyshire was the highest ranking leader that I had the ability to work with directly. I was in his entourage. He was very sharp.
I've been at a couple of speaking engagements with him, and we've had some conversation in person and by phone.
And he is even at, I think he's maybe 80 now, 81. But he's still light on his feet. He Bobby was a stand-up comedian. He was also a jazz drummer.
So he was the working man type of the jack-of-all-trace. He was a sheet metal mechanic. He was in the military.
So he brought the organizational skills to the Panther Party. He brought the energy, a lot of the drive. Newton was more of the philosophical force within the party, the chief theoretician.
And people just loved him because of his brilliance and because of his, as some people have noted, because of physical beauty.
But Bobby, he's able to keep his mind sharp and as a pleasure working with him.
So I think it's possible for us to take a second to go.
We've just taken a short break and we're back. And Mr. Hopkins, I thought I'd ask about the perhaps related questions, say, of, think about the state's response to groups like the Panthers and other assertive social justice and social change groups.
I think about co-entell phone call. And I'm wondering if you have, you might have more to say about your experiences, but that kind of reaction from the state or the police apparatus on the one hand and also if, if you have reflections on another practice of the state in the current, the most recent generation, which is this vast expansion of the penal system and incarceration of the state.
Especially after the American.
Yes. They on a personal level. And I'm not, you know, I'm not sure how this related to my later turn toward criminality.
You know, I guess if people, researchers, or those who view this tape don't necessarily know.
After returning from Oakland and in dealing with the chronology, my development, I left Oakland so disillusioned.
And I still felt to a certain extent that I had a responsibility of taking care of my family and then I married shortly after my return.
At the same time, I was so anti, I was so anti everything as a matter of fact.
I wanted to to live the life of an outlaw to a certain extent. And I decided to rob a bank for which I was arrested and sentenced to 10 years in prison.
And upon my return afterwards, I would say then I was probably more of an alienated artist than anything else.
And after two years, I found myself back in prison with a life sentence, ironically from an all-white jury in Danville, Virginia for robbery in which no one was physically injured.
So, enjoying together, you know, they say in one of the models and the party was repression, breeze, resistance.
Now, this attitude and the attitude of having been repressed because when I joined the party in Winston-Salem, we were under attack by both the police forces
and or the party had been under attack just prior to my joining by police forces and by white racial supremacists.
The previous headquarters had been fire bombed. They didn't have a headquarters at the time that I joined. And there had been shootouts, the previous couple of years there in Winston-Salem,
and they were shot at the police or the police shooting in one case and then in high point it was an actual shootout because party members were told to defend their headquarters whenever they were surrounded and not to allow entry by the police forces,
and they were treated to shootouts across the nation and the killings of dozens of panthers and a few police officers.
So, this attitude, I used to stand watch with a shotgun at night, we all all panthers had to stand guard duty.
So, I'm not necessarily sure what that had to do with my later bend toward criminality as I say. I seldom put it on my political upbringing, but at the same time the rage that I developed against the system in the party possibly had something to do with it.
Now, during this particular time, one of the tennis of the platform program of the party was that no black man has had an adequate and fair jury trial by jury of his peers.
And therefore, all black men in prison should be freed because they are in effect all political prisoners.
Well, I don't quite go along with that and I'm not sure that we totally went along with it then, but if one were to study the writings of Joyce Jackson said that there was an inverse ratio proportionate between the numbers of millionaires in the world and the numbers of prisoners in the world or in the United States.
Looking at the rise of incarceration in the country, one has to see one that there are many causes and factors. Some of them are cultural, some of them are due to repression by police forces, some are racial in nature, but most have to do with the drug war.
And the way the drug war has been waged against people of color, but all people. Now, there's also a cultural factor in that the motto of resistance in the black community has also led among our youth to...
an attitude of cultural rejection and a lifting up of the culture of the streets. And a lot of criminologists and a lot of people don't necessarily want to talk about this.
And then a lot of talked about it and then have just given up and say that, oh, you're just deriding rap music and the skanks to rap and no one is ever yet proven that there's a connection and what can you do about it?
And then, you know, the Yada, well, there is definitely a connection and one of the things that I try to show in my book is my personal development. And others have tried to show this or have tried to show this is that in the absence of a black path of party, I think one commentator filmmaker made a film called The Bastard's.
The Bastard's of the party, saying that in the absence of the path of party, this attitude of resistance went into sort of a fracture of side on the type of gang versus gang blood versus crypts type of activity.
To a certain extent, if one does not have a philosophy and an understanding of one's history in terms of understanding human progress, you know, as far as our reason for being here in the first place, then our young people almost naturally turn toward hedonism and an out of mystic...
movement toward that which is regressive and tribal in nature. So one of the things that in working with young people and developing a hero, I mean, an ideal of hero development or hero ideation, as I call it,
one sees that the attitude of resistance that was part of our survival in the black community is now sort of utilized by young people who have no understanding of who they are and what they're about
and what they're about is saying, well, I've had young people to tell me where you were a Panther, you had guns, you know, and with no understanding of what the guns were for.
I'm also going to ask about... That was a long answer. And somewhat convoluted, but...
Tell me about your sense of the party in some sense as an extension of the Malcolm X.
Okay, right outside the second part, I don't think I finished the second part of the question. Now, the incarceration craze was...
It was something that the party... We dealt with the imprisonment of black men and women to a large extent, but we had no idea that it would come to what it is come to now.
So, to a certain extent, you have the degeneration of a certain strata in the black community that leads to a need for a certain amount of incarceration, but not of the nature that it is now.
At the same time, you have a force within the larger community which says, we need to lock them up and throw away the key.
You have a greater emphasis towards fear and the fear of criminality.
And I was watching a thing with Ellie Spissel last night and he was saying, we don't think of the greatest criminals among us as being white collar criminals.
But they steal more than the common everyday hudelome, ever can, or ever could, or would.
But so, to deal with the incarceration, looking at some say it's the new civil rights issue of the day, some say it's education, which is one of the issues that we dealt with in the party and in the civil rights movement,
and also some say that it's incarceration and that incarceration is the new Jim Crow.
There's some truth to both of those in situating the legacy of the civil rights movement and the fact that the black nationalist movement and the black liberation movement
and the black path of party, how they sit within the framework of all of these, the fact that people don't know what the black path of party was about.
People don't know what snake was about. People don't necessarily know what Kwame Ture and Stokely Carmichael, other than they think it was just a hate whitey type of thing.
For that matter, people don't know what the SDS was really about. Young people, it's not just African Americans who need to understand their history. Young whites need to understand their history of the progressive movements in this country.
Because of this and not understanding our heritage, then the world actually went into it, heated nism and just getting what we can.
So, in prisons.
Yes, kids nowadays a lot of it has to do with understanding story.
And I think also understanding the difference between an idol and a hero.
A lot of times nowadays, because history has been whitewashed, we don't necessarily understand, for instance, who were the heroes of the civil rights movement other than Martin Luther King?
You know, it's one of the things that this whole project is about some of the lesser known heroes, some of the people who, for instance, I didn't know that a Virginia native had helped to put a snake together and still can't remember a name.
You know, she's one of my heroes. Do you know of whom I'm speaking? The woman who helped found snake, but she wasn't a member.
I think she was a delicate to the Democratic National Convention as well, the first Fisk University meeting.
Yeah, I think so. No, she was a member. Yeah, this was the mentor of that whole group. But in any case, you know, she became one of the Virginia heroes.
But the young people, they don't necessarily see a connection because they don't understand what progress is, because the powers that be don't necessarily want them to think progressively.
You know, they want them to really think in terms of a, I don't know what they want the kids to think.
They want them to be cogs and a machine. They want, when they talk, since they're having a youth program here, they say, well, we want to prepare these young people for jobs.
You know, we want to do job training instead of educating these kids how to live. You know what I mean? How to keep a job, you know, not just work on a job.
So I think that heritage enrichment, what the, I think it's all part of not just understanding the truth, but also an understanding and developing a sense of cultural justice.
You know, if you just have justice for in terms of black and white, you obey the law, this then the other.
But there is also a cultural, as well as an economic justice involved, you know, the haves and the have-nots.
But also a cultural justice, you know, you have an of which the robbing of the culture and the identity of African people was just the most egregious.
You know, you look at what happened with people to understand what happened with the Irish or with the, let's say the Mexican Americans, they don't understand how,
what happened to the African influence in Mexico, the Dominican Republic, the Chinese and their contributions to this country.
You know, the French or the Germans, you know, how the Germanic influence, like all of a sudden because the Germans got a bad name because of Hitler.
So they don't understand, you know, the effects of German philosophy in terms of culture, of the Germans, of Russian literature.
You know, we don't think of each other as part of the harmony of interests.
You know, Barack Obama, President Obama, he talks about winning the future as if it's a space race, as if it's a race against China instead of an effort to cooperate with China.
You know, these are the philosophical underpinnings that the history and the culture that you are bringing out and that the museum is bringing out, it relates to our cultural justice and trying to achieve a higher state of man, you know.
And to educate the emotions, but in educating the emotions, the problem is that the stories that are told, they aren't trying to educate the emotions, but to titillate the emotions.
You know, to titillate.
Yeah, and in order to, and part of this is, and lately I've been going back to the philosophy that I learned while I was in the party, and part of this is because we have our kids believing in the metaphysical.
You know, we have them believing in, and whatever they can see on television and in film can be real.
We have them believing in Harry Potter-ism, to a certain extent, in the supernatural.
And, you know, and to a certain extent, the brain evolved so that it can believe what it sees.
And believing controls much of what we do.
So if a child is seeing stuff on the TV screens, on the video screens, they believe that magic can be real instead of that magic is simply what it is in Lucerie.
So let me take you back to this additional point that I know you want to discuss and your thoughts, how you saw the party as an extension of the Malcolm and Summers back.
Well, yes, the party was founded just after the assassination of Malcolm X.
And at one time, I think Bobby Seale and Hughie Newton even thought about calling it the Sons of Malcolm.
But they felt like they wanted to go even further in the development of their philosophy, which, you know, Malcolm X was assassinated while he was still developing a fairly ecumenical, more worldly view, political struggle.
And he talked about things like running for office, working within the system as we've seen in the very beautiful and wonderful work by Manning Marable that he inspired me with finishing in the fact that he was going around with an oxygen tank while still doing interviews.
So the black Panther Party should be seen or might be seen, where actually should be seen in my view as an extension of the Malcolm X philosophy, maybe even more so than what Stokely Carmichael did in terms of, because Stokely sort of went more toward a path.
And the black Panther Party took what we call an international philosophy or what Hughie Newton called an intercommunal philosophy, saying that the world was more a group of communities than nations anymore.
You've been so tremendously generous with your time and all this effort or any finer thoughts that you've used.
Well, one of the things that I talked about was the absence of a lot of pride, you know, the legacy of the Panther Party, I think, is a political legacy, but it's also a legacy of pride and of courage in the face of the world.
The idea that we were inferior, you know, we debunked that notion by showing that power could be attained as we were taught, power is the ability to define a phenomena and make it act in a desired fashion.
So that is one of the reasons we were always studious, we had political education classes. And, you know, so it was the ability to utilize the mind, and we were taught that the mind itself was the highest form of organized matter known to man, and then to have the courage to make it act in a desired fashion.
So in a sense, it was a continuation of the Malcolm X philosophy or combining Malcolm with Martin, if you will. So the legacy lies in how we get our young people to understand that sense of activism, which I think came out during the election of Barack Obama.
This is a very common problem to the presidency and to a certain extent that legacy has been seen in Egypt and around the world.
Also, I'd like to talk about the power of love.
There was a cohesiveness with the party.
There was also a lot of what we used to call self-hate
within the black community, where you ain't nothing,
you never will be nothing, that sort of thing.
So, but within the party and what inspired me
was the love that we had for one another
and the love and the ideal of service to the community,
which is one of the things that I'm also trying to teach
and exemplify in working with various programs
that we need to learn to have an ideal
of service to humanity, to something larger than ourselves.
And I think this is part of the legacy of the party.
The idea of progress is something I think that we've sort of
lost, you know, I think the idea of progress has gone
toward technological progress rather than philosophical
or human progress.
And I think that understanding heritage
and the heroes of our past can help toward that ideal of progress.
And the idea of not just cultural justice,
but economic justice.
This is one of the things that, you know,
sometimes people talk about economic justice
in terms of having contracts for minorities, suppliers,
or having women integrated into the workplace.
But when you look at what's happening
with the union movement and how it's attacked at every turn,
how service workers are being attacked at every turn,
you know, it shows that we have gotten away from understanding
the hard-fought gains of the labor movement
and how that was related to not only the ideal of progress
that we had as a people, but that many employers had,
for a while, for their employees,
that many of the upper class had in terms of giving
or some of them still have it now in terms of the philanthropic movement.
And so, you know, in the party we used to talk about
the redistribution of the wealth.
It was by whatever means necessary,
but no one's talking about that now.
But when you look at the ideological divide in the country
and the fact that the Republicans and many in the country
have as so the Tea Party movement that the people vote against their own interests,
you know, instead of voting for their interests,
they vote to have tax cuts for the rich.
So really it's sort of like an idolatrous relationship with the rich.
And much of this people don't talk about it,
but much of this is related to race, you know?
Many working class whites still see blacks and Hispanics
as being a threat, and they see the Republican Party
as helping to stem that threat.
They see the Democratic Party as being a party that loves black people
a little too much, you know?
So all of these things, by having this disconnect from history,
a young people don't really understand, you know?
And I sort of close with this anecdote,
but there was a student who goes to this high school
called the Maggie L. Walker Governor's School.
There was school here named after Maggie L. Walker.
I'm writing a play and probably a film
and maybe even a novel about Maggie L. Walker
and have been for years, I mentioned it in my book.
But Maggie L. Walker was a turn of the century black woman
who founded a bank and it was the older surviving black bank
until a few years ago when it was bought out.
But she had a, where they called it a secret society,
but it was the independent order of saying,
you loop, which was a burial society,
and they had over 100,000 members from New York
to North Carolina at one point.
But anyway, this school, they took a school,
a governor school and moved it into the Maggie L. Walker School
which was at one time the segregated black high school.
So now it's predominantly white.
And they had a girl who was in the young Republicans club
who was on TV and she looked like the,
she was a European American
and she looked like a debutante, quote unquote.
And she was talking about being a young Republican.
Well, of course, Maggie L. Walker was Republican at that time,
but I just thought about the irony of this school
and because I've had people who had kids
in Maggie L. Walker School and they had the foggy,
or at least the parents did of who Maggie L. Walker was.
So.
We hope somehow that one, one,
sure.
And you and the girl who was going to be calling herself,
what was that?
The counter intelligence program by the FBI
begun a large measure to combat the rise of a,
quote unquote, new black Messiah.
It was used.
I think it was, it actually was formulated
before Martin Luther King's death.
Some people have credited the use of various dirty tricks
against Martin Luther King that helped lead his demise.
But it was also used to lead to the demise
of the black Panther Party to Foment,
disunion among the party.
There were poison pin letters sent from one party member
to other party members talking about Huey.
It was used to form a split between Erich Cleaver
and Bobby Seale.
It was used to imprison Elmer "Geronimo" Pratt,
or Elmer "Geronimo" Pratt as he preferred to be called.
And it was used to attack various other institutions
on the left.
And you know, it, sometimes I wonder what my life
might have been like because I was going to stay
in Winston Salem and go to Winston Salem State University
and organize.
But someone from COINTELPRO went to Winston Salem State.
They were about to offer me, I was up for their scholarship
and they said that no, he's a Panther.
The Panthers from Winston Salem went to Virginia
and got the most intelligent high school senior.
They could find and brought him back here
just to infiltrate Winston Salem State.
Until a certain extent, when I found out about this,
it made me angry and led to me making the decision
to go out to Oakland, California, to forego university studies.
So you know, it worked in rather than city-as-way.
You just followed the information I had for a question.
No, I looked up what was online
and I found that they had followed me from Danville, Virginia
and to Winston Salem and noted my arrival in Winston Salem.
And when I was researching my book, you know, I started to,
but I felt it would fuel too much anger
to find out just how deeply they may have
you know, it was also like,
it was almost like we never had a chance, you know,
we weren't given a chance with what we were doing.
At the same time, you know, George Jackson used to say
revolution is against the law.
So what do you expect, you know,
and Huey Newton criticized the fact
that we almost invited some of the repression against us.
And sometimes when I think about that and I look at what's going on
over in the Middle East now and in Africa,
they call Libya, the Middle East as if it weren't or Egypt
as if they weren't in Africa.
But you look at what's going on in Libya in particular
and I say, well, you know, what would the United States be doing
if armed insurrection were breaking out here
and look what it did do when there were just peaceful protest,
not necessarily comparing the United States to Libya,
but there are some comparisons that can't be made.
That's the most embarrassing, I don't know if it was an elevator.
It's a good sound.
Yeah, yeah.
You just need to be put in this elevator.
Right.
Elevator.
Elevator, yes.
We really want to thank you for such a very, very genuine session.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.